welcome back Alan dragu here and today
we're going to be talking about the
exact copyrighting routine that I do
every single day to help me stay sharp
and get tremendously better at my
copyrighting every day in fact a lot of
you guys have read the book Atomic
habits and in atomic habits he talks
about that get 1% better every day is
365 over the year Well I believe in that
very much except I double it I do 2%
every single day so you can do half of
what I do in still be really really good
but if you want to see exactly what I'm
doing every single day let's Dive Right
In God bless that is so good fantastic
all right to break it down and to be
honest my copyrighting routine is
actually pretty dead simple it's not
fancy uh it doesn't take a lot of effort
nowadays I mean it did in the beginning
but you're going to need focus and
you're going to need discipline and
you're going to need to take this
seriously and if that's not you if
you're not looking to put in any effort
whatsoever I would go ahead and just
move on to another video okay we put an
effort we do the work around here and
that's how we grow otherwise see you on
the next one so to jump into my
copyrighting routine it's really broken
down into four parts okay it's writing
studying reading and incubating okay
that is four different levels and it
actually takes me about 2 hours per day
not a major time commitment okay some
people can squeeze in 2 hours some
people can't I've got a wife three kids
a career a workout routine a church I
volunteer at all these things right you
can squeeze in 2 hours a day if you are
taking this seriously but if not no big
deal all right so each one of them is
broken down to about 30 minutes and the
first one is writing okay I spend my
first 30 minutes in my copywriting
routine actually writing that could be
500 Words it could be a th000 words to
to be honest though I'm not going to lie
I probably spend a lot more time than 30
minutes writing a lot of times I get
into the flow and I'll go for an hour
hour and a half sometimes if I have the
time but I only really commit myself to
saying if I get in 30 minutes like I'm
good and there's definitely days where I
just do 30 minutes right there's days
where I'm not really feeling it I'm not
I'm not in a Groove and I'm just going
to clock out at the 30 minute Mark but
as long as I get my 30 minutes I feel
good about that so get your 30 minutes
in and that could be writing an email
that could be uh writing a copy of a
sales page right if you're just learning
a sales page and you want to hand write
it or if you want to hand type it right
that could be writing it could be
writing uh a video sales letter uh your
own sales letter it could be writing
Facebook ads Google headlines it could
be writing tweets threads uh medium
articles right whatever you are writing
copy for just write for 30 minutes right
you can freewrite where you have no
agenda just write what's in your head
you can make up a product that you're
writing for you could go online find a
product you really like like I like
guitars and I like books I like guitar
pedals
I could go write about a guitar pedal
that I found online and do a sales
letter for them even though they never
hired me you can go write for your
clients just get 30 minutes of writing
in the second part to my copyrighting
framework is about the next 25 35
minutes and that I stole from Gary
beninga one of the most prolific and
profitable copywriters ever alive if
you've not heard of Gary beninga go
Google him because he is incredible he
has sold over $1 billion in direct
response advertising and his thing for
the 1% a day right to get better to stay
sharp to stay in that top tier is to
read and add a day you've probably heard
the old add ofen apple a day keeps the
doctor away well an add a day makes for
a very profitable copywriter and what I
do for that is I go to a website called
swiped.co okay put the link right there
you can go to swiped.co and you can type
in whatever you want in whatever Niche
whether it's the actual copywriter
itself like if you go to swipe. co and
type in Gary Banga you'll see a couple
of the ads that Gary Ben angero and
often times I will go on swipe. and I
will print I physically print because
I'm a physical guy I like to look at
them and read them I will literally
print it look at it and I'll have a pen
and I'll literally study the sales
letter so this is the study part of my
framework while fig oh look at the word
he used wow he used urgency here look
how specific that part was I love how he
did the deadline there proof proof proof
proof whatever I'm doing I'm studying a
sales letter to identify Y what are the
Masters doing and doing this for about
30 minutes right you might not get
through an entire sales letter you might
not get through an entire ad I do this
with emails a lot of times when I read
Ben settle's emails and Daniel thel's
emails I'll study their emails um but
either way this is just a very
intentional part for you to pay more
attention to the stuff that you're
reading it's going to get you a lot
sharper and it's actually going to Ed
into your bones very much like what Gary
Halpert said was it just soaks in your
bones and you're going to feel it the
next time you write which leads me to
the next 30 minutes and that is reading
about copyrighting okay so this is a
part where it's not studying there is a
difference studying copywriting where
I'm like by hand effort I'm paying
attention that is very different than
this step where I'm going to take a book
right that I think is really well
written sometimes it's a copyrighting
book that's teaching me more about
copyrighting sometimes it's a novel that
has nothing to do with copyrighting but
it's just wonderful storytelling because
there's so much story in copyrighting
and sometimes it may be more sales
letters or or or emails that I love to
read or course that I'm reading anything
like that but it's but it's intentional
reading that I'm just enjoying myself
and soaking in that more knowledge and I
do this for about 30 minutes again at
night before bed I might read another 15
20 minutes okay and the last part of my
copyrighting routine is the most skipped
part incubation okay incubation As Told
by Joe Sugarman in his copywriter
handbook is time spent away from the
copywriting right after you just did
some intense study or some intense
writing okay so if I just did 30 40
minutes of salesletter writing and I
studied a sales letter okay I've got a
lot of thoughts brewing in my head I'm
trying to figure some stuff out a lot of
times I will step away from my desk and
go for a walk for about 30 minutes where
I'll just think I'll just enjoy the walk
or I'll go play some tennis or something
like that to incubate my mind okay let
things Fester up and what this does is
it allows your subconscious to start
connecting the dots to the things you've
been really intensified focus on all
right and when it starts connecting the
dots you're going to start having more
aha moments and those aha moments could
be the headline that you would have
never thought of the sub headline
bullets okay it would have been an idea
that you saw while studying the product
but you didn't pay much attention until
now incubated in your head and so
incubation is a crucial part of
copyrighting and again the every legend
that I know Gary beninga Gary Halper
John Carlton Clayton makepiece all these
guys Jim ruts they all focus on
incubation is part of the process okay
that is a professional part of the
copyrighting journey so don't skip that
out to recap of the 2hour daily routine
it is writing for about 30 minutes again
could be 500 words could be a thousand
words doesn't matter writing for about
30 minutes studying for 30 minutes okay
getting a sales letter getting an ad
getting something and studying it very
relentlessly reading for about 30
minutes okay infest your mind with good
copy with good thinking healthy thinking
you don't need to scroll for 30 minutes
you need to read for 30 minutes and
lastly is incubation let that stuff
Bubble Up and connect itself so you can
write the best copy possible and hey to
wrap this up if you can't do 2 hours a
day maybe you start with an hour a day
okay 15 minutes 15 minutes 15 minutes
and 15 minutes okay 15 minutes of
writing 15 minutes of study 15 minutes
of reading and 15 minutes of incubation
you could start a lot smaller it did
take me some years to actually get here
so I can't say that beginners are going
to be able to do this right off the bat
however I am going for that top 1% and
so I take my craft very seriously and I
will be one of the top paid copywriters
in the world and so if you want to do
the same you should follow the same suit
as this is what I'm building and before
we wrap up today I'm going to give you a
couple things to study for free you can
actually hit the link in the description
below and grab copyrighting Catalyst
which is 63 cash cow copyrighting tips
that I've put together over my study for
the last few years for you to have for
free you could take that and you can
study a lesson every single day put it
to practice and that is a great way to
juice up your copyrighting skills thank
you again for watching I hope hope you
enjoyed make sure to hit the like and
the Subscribe button if you found this
video valuable and I will catch you on
the next one okay some bonus tips if you
want some good reading cashvertising
Ogle V on Advertising breakthrough
advertising woo that is a banger book
you're going to really enjoy that